Mario is a hero right savior of the
Mushroom Kingdom beloved by millions who
doesn't crack a smile when they see this
beanie Mario don't be fooled
underneath that red happen bushy
mustache lies an absolute monster okay
maybe not absolute monster but Mario's
got a few dry bones in his closet when
it comes to being kind of a video game
creep in fact Mario's penchant for
cruelty has been right in front of our
faces for decades and just fine we
called it out for all to see
Super Mario Odyssey Mario's next big
opportunity to redeem himself will be
out in winter 2017 let's review why
mario has been a menace for over 35
years
animal cruelty Donkey Kong's reign of
terror against Mario isn't just the big
ape giving in to his animal nature some
time before the events of the original
Donkey Kong
Mario ran a circus and his pet Kong was
the main attraction in the game and
watch titled Donkey Kong circus players
control a captive Donkey Kong while a
menacing Mario watches Kong is forced to
roll left and right on a barrel juggling
pineapples while also avoiding fireballs
just look at Donkey Kong's face every
moment of this is pure torture sooner or
later the player and therefore Kong is
going to mess up and that's when Mario's
cruelty is on full display when Congress
a pineapple or get scorched by a
fireball Mario heartlessly points on
laughs this is animal cruelty
plain and simple no wonder Donkey Kong
wanted revenge cruel and unusual
punishment speaking of that revenge
after Mario saves Pauline from Donkey
Kong's clutches he Luck's his nemesis in
a cage and takes him prisoner that's
understandable considering the big guy
just kidnapped his girlfriend
but when Kong's son tries to save him
Mario goes well Valon super villain to
try and kill a baby ape in Donkey Kong
jr.
Mario sends vicious bear traps killer
birds and the living electric sparks on
a mission to maim and murder the young
gorilla
while his horrified father watches from
his cage that's why it's so satisfying
to see Papa Kong kick Mario square in
the face and the game's final cutscene
POW right in the moustache brick buster
you see Mario shuttle blocks right aside
from jumping it's pretty much his
signature move what if we told you every
time that mario breaks the block he's
actually taking a life it's true in the
or for the original Super Mario Brothers
Nintendo explains that when the Cooper
invaded the Mushroom Kingdom and took
Princess Peach hostage the quiet
peace-loving mushroom people were turned
into mere stones bright and something
called field horsehair plants which
appears to be a mistranslation since
Nintendo changed it to mushrooms when
the game was re-released in Super Mario
all-stars but the part about them
getting turned into bricks that didn't
change so every time Mario jumps into
the air and punches a brick he's killing
one of the very civilians he sets out to
save or consuming them in mushroom form
to grow into Super Mario if there's a
coin inside the block it's even worse in
those cases not only is Mario murdering
mushroom Foulke he's robbing their
corpses too
not a good look Mario Mario is a
lothario for a short fat guy with
ill-advised facial hair Mario gets
around after donkey kong mario ditched
Pauline for peach and the while she's
been his main squeeze ever since peach
isn't the only princess in Mario's life
in Super Mario Land he enjoys a brief
fling with Princess Daisy that's right
the woman who's portrayed as Luigi slew
in games like Mario Tennis NES Open
tournament and the Mario Kart actually
made a big debut as Mario sidepiece in
Super Mario Land after besting the evils
of hangar and a one-on-one dogfight
Mario and Daisy hop into Mario's plane
for a romantic cruise through the clouds
in the end game cinematic marry you and
Daisy embrace and a single heart floats
above their head face it folks
Mario is a player and a terrible brother
brotherly shove if anyone has suffered
at Mario's hand it's his brother Luigi
when there's a second player around
Luigi works just as hard of his older
siblings first gets nowhere near the
credit and when the ouija finally got to
star in his own adventure for the first
time it was a dreaded edutainment game
with Mario's name not Luigi's in the
title what a slap to the face even worse
in Super Mario Sunshine
Mario peach and some toes go on vacation
but don't even invite Luigi so when the
ouija finally wins it all in Mario power
tennis a celebration is a long time
coming and so Mario ruins it first Mario
crashes the stage kanye style then he
slaps luigi on the back a few times
before doing this
what a sicko watch your back Mario Luigi
is coming for you trying to get Dino
slaughter imagine for a second that you
are Yoshi you and your family works to
return the two lost babies to their
parents even though the little ones are
being chased by monsters and they make
the most annoying sounds of all time
decades later an evil turtle in a flying
clown head takes over your homeland
captures your friends and the luck
stomach and castle basements all over
the world and it turns you into an ex
later a human saves you and it happens
to be the same little boy you rescued so
many years ago all grown up and able to
fend for himself
amazing you'd think maybe he'd treat you
with a little respect right wrong one
proof throughout the series and marry
your jumps off of Yoshi's back while
it's Dino palace jumping letting him do
a sort of mega jump that's good for
Mario
but often works out pretty bad for Yoshi
given that the zone of sacrifice usually
happens while the pair are hovering over
a bottomless pit or a fall of lava
don't let Mario off the hook by assuming
you she magically comes back to life
either as Yoshi's Island confirmed there
are many many Yoshi's out there so that
twisted creep Mario is probably just
offering them one by one until there are
none left
[Applause]
Mario escapes for mayhem is clearly
insatiable thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]